we said 43 we might round that to the
nearest ten
do you remember that so we said one of
the tens of the curstyn that this 40 and
is 50 right so when you go up you have
to add that much if you go down you have
to subtract that much and so you can
clearly see which is the better option
which is the closer so that's why we
would say 43 rather support so that's
really good after you call that how
would you buy another new example that's
right let's all write down a new number
like so here's a number isn't them and
I'm again interested in trying to make
this a little easier to work what a
gross number it's really really nasty if
I had to add something to this is me
heaps carrying lots of little spots or
ears to come in okay so if I read out
this number is 24 million three hundred
fifty nine thousand and eighteen okay so
I said it's not three numbers well three
numbers it's one number I it's worth
mentioning and people are different
schools that you go to some of you will
have written it just without the
comments you don't need to write this
but these are the same number I just
wanted to try and make clear I can't
that's that's why commas are there just
so it's a little easier to see
okay so he's our mama we're interested
in rounding right now suppose I said to
you well I want to make this easy run
with it what two questions I should have
in my mind when I'm rounding you might
remember we're number one number two two
things that we keep in mind when every
round so no one remember what the first
one was Christian how accurate would you
like to be perfect so I could be
accurate to the nearest ten or there's
hundred or thousand or anything that I
deem appropriate depending upon doing
this number that's the first question
hold on what was the second question and
of four excellent so once I know how
accurate I want to be I just think
what's the one above it
what's the one below it and then I work
out from there so what do you think
might be an appropriate accuracy to the
nearest anti-drip whatever for this
number any suggestions what do you
reckon okay sure you're thinking a
millions fantastic I think millions is
not a bad thing to go for that's in fact
write that down down
to the nearest million
we're going to about this to the nearest
million so I decided how accurate I'm
going to be now you might think Millions
that's not very accurate at all you're
missing hundreds of thousands of things
but you know what like if you talk about
the population of a country this is
roughly the population of Australia we
talk about the population in their
countries all the time in millions
because countries are big things right
okay great that's the nearest million
the second question was which one is the
closest one so there's a million that's
below it and a million that's above it
someone hasn't say you can get yeah go
ahead
24 and it's we're doing millions right
so it'll be 24000 let's make 4,000 and
then another zero zero there's at 24
million okay so that's because just one
below what's the next one yeah okay it's
just it's just the next million oh it's
a twenty five zero zero zero zero zero
okay I'll gonna pause for a second right
up in this question here I said okay
well I can actually work out what the
difference is it's not that hard right
but here I don't usually want to work
out how much I have to go often it
that's actually quite a hard question
isn't it like to do that subtraction
doing this one is not so hot but it's
still a bit of a pain okay but
interestingly I think all of you kind of
have a bit of an instinct as to which
one is closer they don't want to shout
out what they think yeah twenty-four
million is closer right now admittedly
I'm giving you a number that I think
it's pretty easy to tell right 359,000
ish again a random estimating that's
going down it's gonna have to be
something like 600,000 to go up almost
double right so clearly it's putting
tick on it clearly 24 million is the
ones
but but you know that better than this
we can do it again petitions love it to
be lazy and efficient we don't even need
to write out all of those zeros think
about this we come back and write down
every to know about one more time just
without all this stuff around it okay so
here's the reason number 24 now you
remember when we asked that question how
accurate would you like to be another
way of saying that is well which of
these digits is going to be kept and
which one's going to change right so
think about this you've got and you can
name them with me in fact less this name
is right these are the units which means
max one-third tens tens of hundreds and
thousands ten thousands a hundred
thousand supports all of those units we
just mentioned right in its tents etc
turn it up warm up to a hundred thousand
hundreds of thousands right there was
fall of the millions did you notice that
so that's why all of those digits here
and you might like to draw a Harris to
these ones all of these digits are the
ones that will change
they're all going to change to zero
right they're all going to get rounded
to zero zero zero zero zero zero what
really matters is the next number after
that right so I've got another color
gear okay this is the one where all the
business is happening see that one in
fact this question is all about that
number and try to work out
should it be four I should it be five
question yep when you said those
questions six part H is that right okay
so I'm you're going to do two things and
I might deal with that question a bit
more later because we're going to look
at examples of that you could rad once
so you can round twice like you can
round once just to get a nice thick
number and then multiply it by two or
three or whatever the question asks you
if you want you can round again after
that and make it even simpler okay so it
kind of depends on what the question
needs this is return to this guy right
excuse me
you've ever I just said this guy here
the for the millions spot the millions
place right that's where all the actions
happening and you can see in fact what
really matters is just the number after
it right there's the number that's the
millions to the nearest million and when
you look at the number after it if this
one's at all you'll round down and sure
enough three is pretty small so it does
round down just like a ghost if it
rounds if it's a big no pup likes
it's gonna round up it doesn't matter
what anybody's are just that make sense
okay
so Wendy colors here right this is the
digit that gets rounded so she just the
change I should have said to zero you
can add that on the end these all will
change to 0 this is the digit that
either stays the same or goes up
and really which is the digit that tells
us to do tow which is the one that's
most important it's that yes it's that
hundred thousands it's the one right
after the millions okay if that's a
three it actually doesn't matter what
all of these four five nine zero one and
it up they could all be nines and it
wouldn't matter it would still go down
right or if it was a six which I'm six
round six will round up five was that
funny one right which way do we say I've
rounded yeah oh right we decided just
for consistency you know it could go
either way
but we want to make sure we don't get
the same answer okay okay so therefore I
want to one I want to give you a little
bit of a arrived to help you remember
this okay when you are thinking about
this we're good the digits gonna stay
the same or go up and it's the next one
after that
okay so to round so this is kind of like
a summary and we're going to put this at
the end so that you can remember this
and it makes it much quicker you don't
have to write all the numbers out yes
yes please to round okay this is kind of
my conclusion my summary it's nice and
roomy and easy to remember
try look add the digit
after the one being rounded okay so
these ones all go to zero right look at
this one after the one that's being
rounded the four is the millions right
so that's the one that stayed around and
he comes the ride right five or more let
it's all right five six seven eight nine
they all soar upwards and they all round
up okay 500 more let it soar on the
other hand look at them is that one of
those around down sure those ones there
are yeah yeah forum below right so to
make it to make it rhyme I say full full
mess read at rest and that's actually
what we did here right did you see the
number on Fatah the number we're paying
attention to now it's um well it's three
that's four or less isn't it and so the
24 million just stays at 24 minute it
doesn't go up to 25 min so let's quickly
conclude let me show you you don't
survive this pot down we'll just do some
really quickly if I said
again to the nearest million okay what's
it gonna round to and why Sony doesn't
say anything yet yeah yeah fantastic 78
million right and why can we come to a
consensus on why it rounds down and not
up yeah brother
very good it's this guy here right it's
4 or less so you can let this rest it's
not gonna go up to 79 right just we're
gonna do one more plus 2 then you don't
need to write this bit down - ok again
one last time I'm doing this finish
million which way is it going into the
round yeah brother
ok this is the millions digit here so
it's going to get up 154 million and why
why yeah go ahead
yeah good we're looking at this number
right and it is 500 so we're going to
let that store outside beautiful new cue
back here Abbas it makes sense